Donald Trump has over performed the
polls once again he is destroyed his
fellow Republican primary candidates in
the Nevada caucus let's take a look at
the results and see where we came out
Donald Trump killing it 30 delegates at
stake in Nevada Donald Trump almost half
of the votes went to Donald Trump 45.9
percent of the vote which gets in 14
delegates just shy of half of the
delegates at stake in Nevada you'll see
Marco Rubio coming in second place
around twenty four percent will get
seven delegates Ted Cruz third place
21.4 percent will get six delegates and
then one delegate apiece for our good
buddy ben Carson hypnotherapist ben
Carson and John Kasich the most
reasonable guy on the stage dead last
because being reasonable on the
Republican side doesn't do much for you
three point six percent one delegate how
much longer can Kasich stay in this
thing you think I don't know why he's
staying in I did hear a good theory from
one of our interns about why Carson is
staying in right and that is because the
longer he stays in the more appearances
he has on his campaigns dollar and he
can sell books right so that kind of
does make sense to me Kasich they have
to imagine the end is is coming soon
some interesting notes from the entrance
polls that were done by CNN instead of
exit polls to the caucuses I don't know
why maybe because they're very long or
or I I'm not really sure why anyway
entrance polls were done and I want to
go through some of the incredible areas
where Donald Trump is just dominating in
some of the areas where he's not so
Trump won both men and women easily no
real gender gap for Donald Trump Donald
Trump won all age groups except 17 229
marco rubio won that age group from when
all education levels ranging from the
most educated the least educated Trump
one born again and evangelical
Christians which serve crazy because
just a few years ago he said he wouldn't
even want to ban partial birth abortion
which is sort of like the lowest hanging
fruit for for forgetting somebody to say
yeah we shouldn't have that Donald Trump
won regardless of what the most
important issue was for voters if your
most important issue was immigration
Trump still won if your most important
issue was the economy and jobs Trump won
your most important ish
it was terrorism Trump one if your most
important issue was government spending
Trump one which is insane because we
know that his economic plan would
completely blow up the deficit if you
are concerned about government spending
being too high Donald Trump is the last
guy you should be voting for yet he
still carried that voting group and now
here's where Trump did not do so well
Trump did not win if you were most
concerned with voting for someone who
has a chance of winning the national
election if you went into the Nevada
caucus and said my priority is someone
who can win in November you were most
likely to have voted for Marco Rubio and
if you went in and said I want to vote
for a candidate who shares my values you
did not vote for Donald Trump Ted Cruz
won there so the real question now Louis
becomes will this momentum continued for
Donald Trump I'm going to talk about
that a little bit later in the show uh
because first we have to talk about
something else that happened last night